looking for ways to break down data
silos and enable analytics over data
regardless of where it's stored give me
one minute and i'll show you how with
google cloud big lake
big lake is a storage engine that
extends bigquery storage capabilities
such as fine-grained security
performance caching and sharing to open
formats on multi-cloud object stores
enabling organizations to unify data
warehouses and lakes
maintain a single copy of your data
wherever you choose and make it
uniformly accessible across google cloud
and open source engines including
bigquery vertex ai spark presto trino
and hive using big lake connectors
big lake capabilities extend to data no
matter how it's stored including popular
open data formats such as parquet avro
orc csv and json
queries on big lake tables provide
industry-leading performance powered by
the same technology that underlies
bigquery
apply table row and column level
security policies on object store tables
without having to provide file level
access to end users
big lake integrates with dataplex
allowing you to provide unified
governance and management at scale
you can interact with big lake through
its integrations with other google cloud
products for example you can create
discover and query big lake tables from
the bigquery console
you can do the same thing through a
dataproc notebook
so if you're looking to unify
distributed data and enable analytics
governance and management at scale
take a minute to look at big lake
to learn more check out cloud.google.com
[Music]
you